Speaker 1: All right. This is almost beyond
belief. There is a video of a meeting at which
the Trump riots were planned. You, I mean, lordy,
there are tapes. These are not exactly criminal
geniuses, that's for sure. Look at this Politico
reporting the DOJ has announced a film crew
was present at the January 5th meeting between
leaders of the Proud Boys and the Oath Keepers.
The details provide new evidence of the encounter
between the two groups, whose leaders played a key
role in the breach of the Capitol the following
day. They're not sending their best and brightest
brightest. Prosecutors say a documentary film crew
was present when Proud Boys leader Enrique Tarrio
and Oath Keepers leader Stewart Rhodes met for
30 minutes in an underground parking garage on
January 5th. Now, remember, they've both since
been arrested and charged. The details, revealed
in a Justice Department court filing on Monday
provide new evidence of the encounter between
the two groups, whose leaders played a key role in
the breach of the Capitol the following day. Quote
While in the parking garage, Tarrio told another
individual he had cleared all of the messages on
his phone before he was arrested. Prosecutors
wrote in a filing urging a federal magistrate
judge to detain Tarrio pending trial. Tarrio
further stated no one would be able to get into
his phone because there were, quote, two steps to
get into. It sounds like two step authentication.
Prosecutors say after Tarrio left D.C. that night,
part of a court ordered that he stay away from the
city while facing charges related to his conduct
during a December 2020 rally. He traveled to
Baltimore that evening. Tarrio used the phones of
associates to make a number of calls and to log
back into his encrypted messaging accounts. After
regaining access to his accounts, Tarrio assured
his men his phone had not been compromised.
Reuters first reported on the existence of that
meeting and the FBI's interest in it. Last
month, new details suggest Tarrio played a
more direct role than previously understood. He's
been charged, Stewart Rhodes has been charged, et
cetera. Reuters Report X. Proud Boys chairman
Tarrio ordered detained pending trial
in Capitol riot case. This is also from yesterday.
A U.S. magistrate judge in Miami Tuesday ordered
Tarrio, the Proud Boys chairman, former to
be detained while he awaits trial on charges
stemming from the riots. So that is what we call
pretrial detention now. I've spoken out before
about the problems with pretrial detention in
the United States. It's often applied unfairly,
it's often applied in practice. It ends up
affecting those who don't have money for private
lawyers. We've been talking about this for a very,
very long time. These right wingers only now care
about pretrial detention. I've been talking
about it ten years on the show. They didn't
care. They didn't think there was any problem. Now
they think there is. But there are videos of the
meeting between Tarrio and Rhodes. The people in
the videos have been running around for a year,
and many of them probably thought they were in
the clear. But it appears as though what the
feds are and have been doing is following it all
up the food chain. It's now hit Stewart Rhodes.
It has hit Enrique Tarrio, who knows the
full scope of what's in these videos.
But there is a very good chance that there are
still very, very serious charges coming for
additional people. And I mean, consider, you know,
when this all happened back in January of 2021.
There was maybe the idea among some that
this was all going to be figured out quickly.
Some people might be charged and some might end
up going to jail, prison, et cetera. But we are
now 14 months in and the charges are still coming,
and not even everybody who's going to be charged
has been charged. So the upside is we're now at
hundreds. It might get to thousands of people who
suffer some consequences for their role in the
riot. That would be a very good thing. On the
other hand, I am still completely not optimistic
that really the big insiders because remember,
the real reason that this even got going was the
false belief that the election had been stolen
from Joe, up from Donald Trump by Joe Biden, who
promulgated that it was a bunch of Republicans
and Donald Trump. And Mark Meadows and so on and
so forth. Are they going to be held accountable
now? I still don't think that the vast majority
of them will be. That's a problem. But if people
committed crimes, they should be charged and they
should have the book thrown at them. And that
does appear to be what's happening.
VIDEO Video of the meeting? Unbelievable